[Musik]
48 000 Zöllner sorgen für Recht und
Ordnung in ganz Deutschland sichern
unsere Wirtschaft guten Tag
hakontrolle Schwarzarbeit mit einer
Prüfung arbeiten Sie hier Schum ob die
waren die verkaufen verteuert sind
schützen den Sozialstaat schön guten
Tag und kämpfen gegen den
internationalen
Drogenhandel diei bitte auf Adrenalin
hat man im immer wenn man nicht weiß was
passiert Hall die Polizei mach bitte auf
W jetzt nicht durch die Tür
[Musik]
machen Berlin Tempelhof 6 Uhr Zoll die
Beamten der Finanzkontrolle
Schwarzarbeit rüsten
auf die Einsatztruppe muss heute
Haftbefehle vollstrecken
Sozialleistungen wurden zu Unrecht
kassiert und nicht
zurückgezahlt
also heute haben wir ein kleines Team
mit sechs Leuten zusammengestellt um
offene Haftbefehle zufallstrecken für
die Staatsanwaltschaft Berlin und der
besuchte hat einmal hat er das Geld vom
Jobcenter bezogen als
Sozialleistung und hat nebenher
gearbeitet und dort natürlich noch mal
das Gehalt vom Arbeitgeber bezogen und
dementsprechend ist dem Jobcenter Berlin
finanzieller Nachteil standen was den
sogenannten Tatbestand des Betruges
erfüllt trotz mehrfacher
Zahlungsaufforderungen reagierte der
Beschuldigte nicht jetzt hat das Gericht
eine Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe angeordnet
also Knast statt Kohle hauptinspektor
Mike schwört die Einsatztruppe ein über
Tatbestand Wohnlage und
Zielpersonen ausgeschrieben mit drei
haelen einmal 4000 € einmal
3080 plus no 20 rechtsstrafe also sind
bei 7100 € oder 177 Tage her ist
wohnhft bei seinen Eltern die
Einsatzbesprechung ist grundsätzlich
immer wichtig dass man den eingesetzten
Kräften dann noch mal ganz klipp und
klar sagt wie ist die Gefährdungslage
Vorort wo hat jeder zu stehen an der Tür
und so ein kleinen Überblick zu geben
wie man es einfach haben will dadurch
dass seine Eltern auch dort mit wohnen
würde ich deeskalierend reingehen es
kann vom ganz entspannten Haft bis zuer
Eskalation sein Gefährdungslage kann man
im vorneerein mal abklopfen gucken was
sein könnte aber was passieren wird
wisen wir im Endeffekt nicht eine
gewisse Gefahr ist immer
gegeben irgendeiner Fragen na dann auf
die Fahrzeuge und
los nur dre Autominuten entfernt
befindet sich die Wohnung die Zöllner
arbeiten in Zivil sie wollen unauffällig
Agieren der gesuchte soll nicht gewarnt
werden Moment wenn man die Tür aufmach
oder wenn die Tür aufgemacht wird dann
ist es immer so okay was haben wir jetzt
hier was haben wir es zu tun es ist so
wie man sich es gedacht hat das Team
stimmt alle halten zusammen man weiß wer
dabei ist ich glaube da braucht man
nicht nervös sein Haftbefehle
vollstrecken das gehört zu den täglichen
Aufgaben der Truppe Routine und dennoch
immer wieder eine
Extremsituation das Team der FKS ist
hochkonzentriert jeder Fehler könnte
schwere Folgen haben
[Musik]
schönen guten Tag
her W so
Zeit W sie sich erst
kurzziehen und zwar geht's drum sie
haben V V Jobcenter Leistung bezogen
Sozialleistung und waren parallel
arbeiten ja dafür gibt's zwei Urteile
und dementsprechend hat die
Staatsanwaltschaft jetzt
[Musik]
haftbefehlelassenatzstrafe sie haben die
Möglichkeit die Haftbefehle abzuwenden
und zwar durch die Zahlung
von
7100 € der Betrag muss jetzt undten war
bezahlt werden wenn ich müssen wir sie
erstmal mitnehmen und würden sie in die
JV also
justizverzugsanstalt seebring haben Sie
die Möglichkeit den Betrag okay also
werden wir sie mitnehmen denn sind sie
jetzt formell erstmal in
Gewahrsam wir sind erwachsene Leute der
Transport wird ohne Handschellen sein
denke ich mal wir gehen hier die
erwachsene Leute zusammen runter ich
will hier nicht mehr auf seneringen als
notwendig ist und dementsprechend
arbeiten wir es ganz entspannt
da der gesuchte lebt bei seinen Eltern
dem Sohn bei seiner Verhaftung zuzusehen
ist für die Mutter ein
Schock so großahen tut mir
leid wir haben ja nicht 7000 € jetzt
einfach
so schon fast gedacht der Mann steht ab
sofort unter Arrest zeigt sich
kooperativ und verlässt ohne Widerstand
die Wohnung eine letzte Zigarette in
Freiheit und ein erstes
Eingeständnis es ist natürlich in
Ordnung dass es Hal so ist dass die
Strafe halt angetreten werden muss weil
man Heß keine Leute ja R m den stat und
dann ist das halt so also berereue dass
ich das gemacht habe ja keine Frage aber
was Zoll ich jetzt
machen Flughafen Frankfurt im
internationalen Postzentrum kommen
täglich bis zu 450.000 Sendungen aus dem
nichteuropäischen Ausland an der Zoll
kontrolliert die Post auf zu
versteuernde Warenwerte und verbotene
Inhalte auf jeden Fall elektronisches da
sind nämlich auch Kabel
dabei wir haben jetzt keine
Kennzeichnung drauf gesehen wir gehen
davon aus dass hier das also hier ein
Verbot im Bereich Produktsicherheit
zutrifft wenn eine Gefahr von dem
Produkt ausgehen könnte dass z.B
Sicherung oder Kabel nicht ordnungsgemäß
angebracht sind dass vielleicht andere
Module eingebaut sind die Schäden
verursachen an dem Gerät oder an anderen
Geräten ähm das muss den muss einfach
vorgebeugt werden und das kontrollieren
wir es ist ein Kampf gegen
Produktpiraterie markenfälschung und
Verstöße gegen den
Artenschutz unsere Arbeit ist einfach
wichtig dass das eine Nachhaltigkeit
erfährt dass wir dass wir schauen dass
wir nicht akut alles stoppen können
sondern dass wir für die Zukunft
weiterarbeiten es hat was mit dem Schutz
zu tun vorgefährlichen Produkten bis
chen auch zu Nachhaltigkeit das einfach
geschaut wird dass bedrohte Tiere und
Pflanzen einfach nicht weiter betroffen
sind der illegale Handel mit
artengeschützten Tieren und Pflanzen
floriert nach wie vor trotz Geldbußen
bis zu 50.000 € ja haben wir ein
Krokodil ich würde davon ausgehen dass
das echt ist wenn man sich die
Struktur von den schucken anschaut ja
man sieht auch ganz schön die Naht hier
unten ja ja ist noch mal Indien dafür
ist d ist noch ein Original das ein
echtes Tier ist das schade
drum allein
2022 beschlagnammte der Zoll in
Deutschland 64 000 artengeschützte Tiere
und
Pflanzen 29 Tonnen
Rauschgift und 8,6 Millionen
Produktfälschungen vor allem Drogen
werden immer häufiger per Post
verschickt ein Trend mit Folgen beim
Team der zollfandung in Essen landet
eins der am Flughafen sichergestellten
drogenpakete darin mehr als 1 kilog
Marihuana ja die fer konnten den
Empfänger der Sendung ermitteln ein
junger Mann aus dem Essener Süden das
Amtsgericht hat einen
Durchsuchungsbeschluss
erlassen Stev der Leiter des
rauschgiftdezats bitet die Kollegen z
[Applaus]
Einsatzbesprechung geh darum
durchungsbeschluss des Amtsgericht Essen
umzusetzen let geht natürlich darum sag
gegebenfalls bet sicherzustellen während
der Durchsuchung aber noch wichtiger ist
es gibt ein Handy auf dem Paket war ein
Handynummer drauf die auch z
Identifizierung von beschuigen geführt
hat es könnte nämlich sein dass da
vielleicht schon öfter Sendung waren
wenn er jetzt um Postpakete ja darumen
die nehmen durch auch mit insbesondere
aus Absender USA vielleicht aus Spanien
ja der Beschuldigte ist 27 Jahre alt und
wohnt bei seinen
Eltern Einsatzzeit
6 Uhr wir fahren dahin wir klingeln ganz
normal mit ohne Ramme wichtig ist was
Sicherheit herstellen wer ist also da
vielleicht haben h noch Gäste Freundinn
keine Ahnung weiß ich nicht dass alle
Beteiligten ähm im Haus wissen dass die
der Zoll die Polizei im Haus ist al dass
da keiner den Rücken reinläuft okay sind
wir fertig sehen wir uns morgen früh
alles gut
ja nur Teamwork entscheidet irgendwelche
einzelhelden geht gar nicht
äh da sind Dinge das muss ich auch
einspielen das ist Zahl der Ausbildung
aber natürlich auch Teil des des
Teambuildings und äh wie wie wie die
Einsatzkräfte sich zusammen rckeln das
ist sehr entscheidend weil halt eben
sich am Ende des Tages jeder auf jeden
für sein Leben verlassen
muss die Nacht ist kurz bereits um 5 Uhr
beginnt der Tag für die Beamten der
zollfandung heute steht die
Hausdurchsuchung im Essener Süden an die
Ermittlungen lassen zwar vermuten dass
der Empfänger des drogenpakets nicht aus
dem tiefsten drogenmilieö kommt doch
jeder Zugriff wirgt Gefahren in Zivil
aber schwer bewaffnet beginnt der
Einsatz die Anspannung der Beamten ist
deutlich zu spüren unweit des
Zielobjektes erteilt Stev letzte
Instruktionen alles klar den Plan haben
wir vorne wird der Jörk und D sein Flo
direkt hinter mir ein bisschen abgesetzt
müssen nicht alle vor der Tür stehen
wenn ich dann da reingehe dann werde ich
den wmer sch antreffe sagen wer wir sind
trala dich auch vorstellen dann wen wir
ein bisschen reinsickern wir bleiben in
den Teams wie die war schon besprochen
haben sollen wir vorne bleiben dann
quasi ihr steigt natürlich schon aus ihr
seid ansprechbar durch Zeichen und Sound
und
dann wer wir das Ding erstmal angehen
und gucken wer überhaupt zu Hause ist
ihr seid meine in sichtweit und geh weit
und dann wir halten uns vorom Haus auf
genau ma so
gut
eine gewisse grundanspannung gibt's
natürlich das ist klar aber das
entscheiden ist dass auch alle
funktionieren und das dann der
Eigenschutz für die Beamten und auch
letztendlich auch für die Beschuldigten
das funktioniert 6 km ist man
los die Faher sind Ermittler der
Staatsanwaltschaft und haben
polizeibefugnis im Einsatz stellt der
Zoll sich häufig auch als Polizei vor um
schnell bei allen Beteiligten Klarheit
zu
schaffen ich hoffe auch dass der
Beschuldigte da ist d macht die Sache
einfacher dass wir nicht mit schlüsselen
Seilen müssen gut git Schlüsseldienst
auch aber ist halt für alle beteilig ein
bisschen
komplizierter und ich erwachte einfach
dass wir das ruhig
abarbeiten
ja die Grundintention eines Zollbeamten
ist natürlich immer was zu finden und es
wäre natürlich schön wenn das früher
aufdehen einfach belohnt wird das ist
eigentlich bei jedem Einsatz ist das so
das eine beschauliche Wohnsiedlung in
Essen dass hier Drogen im Umlauf sind
würde man nicht vermuten die Zieladresse
des drogenpakets ist ein
Einfamilienhaus die Faher nutzen den
Überraschungsmoment Beweise sollen nicht
vernichtet werden der Täter keine Chance
zuur Flucht haben hallo die Polizei mach
so bitte
auf Adrenalin hat man im Einsatz immer
weenn man nicht weiß was passiert oband
da ist wie viele da sind wer da ist
hallo ja hier ist die Polizei mach bitte
auf M jetzt nicht durch die Tür machen
können wir vielleicht Aug in Aug
machen die Tür bleibt verschlossen doch
der Zoll darf sich Zutritt verschaffen
er handelt im Namen des
Gesetzes die Kollegen haben geklingelt
das ist offensichtlich jemand zu Hause
und die
anwohner wurden aufgefordert die Tür zu
öffnen dass polizeiliche Maßnahmen vor
der Tür
stehen der Kollege erklärt jetzt ich bin
von der zollfahung ich hab
dursuchungsbeschluss der Kollege kann in
den
aussendigen ich ich verstehe das kommen
unangemeldet ist so können wir mal kurz
reinkommen muss ich die Polizei anrufen
nein die Polizei weiß bescheid die
Mutter ist ahnungslos sie ruft ihren
Sohn er ist die Zielperson kommst Du mal
hier ist eine Truppe von der Polizei
oder ich weiß nicht was der Zoll ich bin
von der zollverhandlung wir haben einen
Durchsuchungsbeschluss wegen des
Betäubungsmittels ich rieche das auch
schon ein bisschen ich habe gestern ein
Gerucht ja ich glaube sie haben auch
schon mal etwas bestellt in den USA wir
haben einen Durchsuchungsbeschluss für
Ihr Haus und ihre Zimmer letztlich geht
es darum dass im März ein Paket
sichergestellt wurde was aus den USA kam
und am Frankfurter Flughafen
sichergestellt wurde was sie bestellt
haben ich habe nichts bestellt das kann
ja jeder machen der ein Paket schicken
ja aber welcher normale Mensch schickt
einem ein Paket für mehrere Taus Euro ja
was weiß ich Ihre Adresse ist bekannt
Telefonnummer und sowas da könnt ihr
einfach irgendjemand zu ihnen allees
schicken könnt ein Kilo Koks ankommen
und da wird direkt die wurde durchräumt
natürlich wird dann alles durchsucht und
wir werden auch Ihr Handy
kontrollieren sie können gern drauf
gucken ja werde ich sowieso können sie
machen aber mein Passwort gebe ich ihnen
nicht also ich gehe davon aus dass er
heute schon Mariana konsumiert hat aber
ist entspannend diskutiert gerne junger
Mann
27 bezüglich des Pakets fühlt er sich
unschuldig gut W mal gucken wir werden
Handy Laptop dann Tablet mitnehmen gut
aber jetzt nicht irgendwie vollstress
oder so redet halt gerne Berlin die
Zöllner der Finanzkontrolle
Schwarzarbeit vollstrecken einen
Haftbefehl der Mann soll unrechtmäßig
Sozialleistungen bezogen und trotz
Aufforderung nicht zurückgezahlt haben
na seit war haltmals Arbeitslose Wesen
und mir fällt halt schwer also mir fel
halt schwer in der Zeit halt Briefe zu
öffnen denke mal die briefer Hal
bestimmt oben in meinem Karton drinne
hat sich aber mit der Zeit
gebessert wusste dass ich das halt
ähm gemacht
habe und
ähm Geld
habe ich halt doppelt kassiert weil ich
damals halt drohabhängig war und nun ist
es halt so dass ich Hal dafür die Strafe
antrete ja denn das unterw B genau
den der Abtransport in die
Justizvollzugsanstalt ist nicht mehr zu
stoppen dass es jetzt ins Gefängnis geht
ist für den Beschuldigten noch nicht
wirklich
[Musik]
greifbar
B
[Musik]
ne ke also kann ich nicht
beschreiben fahren da jetzt hin und
[Musik]
dann so ich muss halt ja mit der
Konsequenz leben also kann jetzt nicht
hier beln und peln und B ist natürlich
nicht so prickelnd jetzt da hinzugehen
od hingfahren zu werden
der Einsatz verlief ohne Komplikationen
Zollinspektor Mike meldet Vollzug ja
habf V streckt und sind jetzt aus euren
Zuständigkeitsbereich wieder raus alle
klar CIA Ciao Einsatz her vom Ablauf her
super der Rest ja und sich jeder sein
eigenes Bild dann
machen aber schön dass mich net
inoll so sagen
bin ja ke bin ja kein böser Mensch
bin einfach
nur so so wie bin halt und das halt
manchmal nicht nicht richtig
wahrscheinlich
so sind ein paar Sachen falsch gelaufen
im Leben und die versucht man jetzt halt
dann denke ich mal auch wieder ein
bisschen gerade zu kriegen sind ja auf
guten Weg also jetzt L wo man sagt das
kriegt man nicht geregelt mit Sicherheit
kann man jetzt noch mal bei Null
anfangen natürlich muss ich von vorne
anfangen
ja
aber das
funktioniert hab ich doch ke Plan
Endstation
Justizvollzugsanstalt Plötzen sie für
den einen beginnt die Haft für den
anderen ist der Auftrag
beendet er wurde jetzt abgeliefert
zwischenzeitlich hat er noch mal seine
Mutter mit mir Kontakt aufgenommen und
mitgeteilt dass er die Strafe jetzt
zahlen wird also denke ich mal dass er
die nächsten ein zwei Tage dann auch
wieder auf freien Fuß sein wird im
Endeffekt der Fall ist jetzt für uns
erledigt und dementsprechend
konzentrieren wir uns auf den nächsten
und werden dann auch
weitermen 24 Stunden später die Zöllner
der Finanzkontrolle Schwarzarbeit und
der Kontrolleinheit Verkehrswege haben
einen gemeinsamen
Einsatz bei dem Objekt müssen wir darauf
achten es ist eine Glasfront ja da
kommen wir rein und haltet euch bitte
links hinten raus geht zu den Toiletten
da befindet sich noch ein privater Raum
und dahinter ist noch mal ein Fenster ja
wenn es irgendwie dazu kommt dass
Personen flüchten möchten dann auch nur
wirklich über ein Fenster was dort halt
vorhanden ist aber seit wird er nicht
kommen wie gesagt machen wir das zweite
Objekt den schish Laden zeitgleich ist
relativ bekannter schish Laden in
Brandenburg gibt keine hinterusgänge
dazu gleich mal hier im Foto sieht da
ist ein Fenster mit Gitter da kommt auf
J Fall keiner
raus die Kollegen Mike und HAK machen
sich auf den Weg im Visier eine
cocktailb und ein
tabakfchgeschäft
Gesetzgeber hat vorgesehen dass wir uns
ein bisschen auf der Straße auf den
Örtlichkeit ge zeigen und
verdachtsunabhängige Kontrollen
durchführen und das ist eine ganz
normale verdachtsunabhängige Kontrolle
2022 hat der Zoll 53 000 Arbeitgeber
kontrolliert rund 160.000 Verfahren
eingeleitet und 700 Millionen Euro
Steuer und sozialversicherungsschäden
ermittelt
gerade in der Gastronomie kommt
Schwarzarbeit häufig vor Zollkontrollen
sind hier eher
unbeliebt ganz normalen pübeleien
über Schubserei und du siehst es den
Leuten oder in den Lokalitäten nicht von
außen an du kannst nicht
sagen du hast Laden von außen gesehen
und dort werden die und die Straftaten
begangen wenn es funktionieren würde wä
es absolut geil man könnte sich eig ne
kann man
nicht hinter der zivilen Einheit machen
sich 14 weitere uniformierte
Einsatzkräfte auf den
Weg
grundsätzlich ist sowas immer gut dass
wir so viele dabei haben einfach aus
eigensicherungstechnischen Gründen
müssen wir immer gucken Küchen oder
barbereiche wo sich Messer aufhalten um
Cocktails herzustellen sind alles
Gegenstände die sich auch uns gegenüber
als Waffe auch benut nutzen lassen wir
sind jetzt vielobjekt paren kurz ein
also theoretisch in einer Minute könnt
ihr dann einständig
losenen mit Blaulicht aber ohne Sirene
fahren die Zöllner vor dann geht alles
ganz schnell die Beamten stürmen
zeitgleich beide
Geschäfte okay fastisch W der
Geschäftsführer oder Angestellte keiner
da Angestellte oder was Schau um ob die
Waren die sie hier verkaufen versteuert
sind und wenn alles gut ist und die
Kollegen von der finentrolle sparbeit
keine weiteren Fragen haben wieder weg
hakontrolle Schwarzarbeit mit einer
Prüfung arbeiten Sie hier
ja
sie die htere ja okay dann h wir einmal
ger die Ausweise bitte haben Sie auch
ein Ausweis
dabei passport irgendwas Foto auf
Handy
okay erstmal so bereit halten Kollegen
kommen gleich noch mal ja aber sie
arbeitet hier
ne okay wir nehmen einmal Ihre
persönlichen Daten auf hab paar Fragen
zum Beschäftigungsverhältnis also das
heißt wie viel Geld sie bekommen für
ihre Arbeit wie viele Stunden sie Arbeit
und und und dann befragen wir Sie und
dann sind wir auch schon fertig ja
einfach nur Routinekontrolle nicht
erschrecken nicht sind einfach überall
so durchkontrollieren und dass wir auch
keine schwarbeit haben mir selber über
30 Jahre hier lebe ich in Deutschland
und arbeiten wir von unser Geld und hier
s die steuen bezahlen und das bin ich
dafür im tabakfchgeschäft nebenan
Zöllner Patrick schaut sich auch in den
hintersten Ecken
um wir sind jetzt hier im Lagerraum
dieses Shisha Shops wo halt seine ganzen
waren
lagert genau da schauen wir uns jetzt um
ob die Tabakdosen die jetzt hier überall
sind ob die am Ende eine steuerband
der Verkauf von Tabak ohne
Steuerbanderole ist steuerherei seit
kurzem gilt das auch für Liquid von
eZigaretten mus
raus
schon
unten
die
ist eine sogenannte Übergangsfrist
abgelaufen und seit diesem Tag oder
Monat müssen diese Sachen versteuert
werden ist die waren hier oben wie be
un wunderbar meine Kiste in der
cocktailbahn nebenan hat die
Finanzkontrolle Schwarzarbeit ganz
andere Probleme am am Ende des Monats
das Geld od Geld Ende des Monats Ende
Monat 31 Tage
also ganz klar die Schwierigkeit ist die
Sprachbarriere zusammen Jobcenter ja ja
be sehr
gut ich geh nicht davon aus dass die
Frau schwarz arbeitet einfach aufgrund
dessen dass sie die unter hat s J Center
gemeldet das war dafür
ein das Team im Tabakgeschäft hingegen
kann Erfolge verzeichnen und es scheint
nobestand zu sein den ke Steuerzeichen
angebracht sind und demzufolge W die
Sachen jetzt erstmal sicherstellen und
gegen den Betreiber hier
steuerstraferfahren wegen
steuerereileiten der
[Musik]
Sachstand die wollten es natürlich noch
abverkaufen kann man auch menschlich
verstehen ne dass die jetzt natürlich
gerne noch ihre Sachen verkaufen wollen
würden aber eben nicht mehr legal
geschätzt haben hier die Beamten einen
Steuerschaden von mehr als 1500 €
vereitelt Hausdurchsuchung der
zollfandung Essen Grund ein drogenpaket
mit 1,1 kg Marihuana der mutmaßliche
Empfänger der Lieferung ist empört ich
finde es unglaublich dass man nicht mal
ein Schreiben bekommt und eingeladen
wird zu einer Anhörung ich find es
unglaublich dass jeder hier in
Deutschland einem ein Paket zusenden
kann kann ja jeder machen das sind dann
die Ausreden die hören wir öfter wir
sprechen von einem
best Mindeststrafe 2 Jahre das wissen
Sie ja nein das wusste ich nicht
undwissenheit schützt vor Strafe nicht
wir machen das nicht um sie zu ärgern
sondern vertreten das
Gesetz die Zöllner haben den Auftrag
Beweise für die Staatsanwaltschaft zu
beschlagnahmen dass ein Zugeständnis
eventuell ein Strafmaß mildern könnte
begreift auch langsam der
Beschuldigte ich habe hier was zu
rauchen kann ich ih das geben können Sie
uns aussendigen alles was wir finden
nehmen wir mit dann will ich das so
vermerken dass sie die Sachen freiwillig
rausgegeben haben der Verdacht auf
weitere rauschgiftverstecke im Haus
verdichtet sich Drogenspürhund Cleo soll
Klarheit schaffen ich soll jetzt nach
unten so das ganze Haus
mal abspüren
gut ist er
da auch relativ große Menge gefunden
aber wie viel das nicht
Betäubungsmittel online aus dem Ausland
nach Deutschland zu bestellen ist
strafbar und wird
verfolgt mit Hilfe des Spürhundes sollen
weitere Verstecke aufgedeckt werden in
den Wohnräumen des Beschuldigten schlägt
die Hündin an friert die Bewegung ein
ein Signal für einen
[Musik]
Drogenfund in den Schubladen wird
weiteres Betäubung
gefunden weit mehr als die für den
Eigenkonsum übliche
Menge ich rauche abends gern mal ein
fucking joint ja das habe ich gemacht
das ist ein bisschen mehr als ein Joint
big Spliff ist das da
unten Marihuana Verpackungsmaterialien
und eine Feinwaage die Beweisstücke
werfen neue Fragen
auf ich habe unverpacktes Marihuana und
Verpackungen
gefunden offensichtig verpacken Sie
diese
Sorten also bei bei bei der Durchsuchung
sind noch ein paar Sachen mehr gefunden
worden auch die ähnliche Dinge auch
leere Verpackung von Marihuana und
feinwag denen wir auch mit weiß ich
nicht dann hätten wir vielleicht den
Tatbestand des Handels was natürch
andere Qualität ist
der Handel von von mit BTM ist natürlich
in dem in dem BtMG wird anders bestraft
als wenn ich ein einkonsum haben wenn
ich natürlich das Equipment dafür habe
irgend Sachen unschön verpackt in schöne
bunte kriptütchen zu packen mit
irgendwelchen Aufschriften könnte der
Verdacht sein dass ich damit Handel dass
ich es weitergebe ist andere Qualität
das sagt der Gesetzgeber
so die staatsanwschaft Gericht drüber
befindet die mindestfreiheitsstrafe für
den Handel mit Betäubungsmitteln in
nicht geringer Menge ein Jahr noch
schwerwiegender ist allerdings der
sogenannte einfuhrschmuggel
mindestfreiheitsstrafe 2 Jahre ich würde
schon sagen dass ich das früher
aufstehen heute für uns alle gelohnt hat
also wir waren tatsächlich bei
jemanden ja nicht an der falschen
Adresse sondern an der
richtigen erste Auswertungen der
Beweismittel legen den Verdacht nahe
dass der Beschuldigte mit Drogen haben
könnte die Ermittlungen im Auftrag der
Staatsanwaltschaft dauern
an